it's a hugely significant moment for
malians who up until now have used the
streets demonstrations to try to get
their voices heard and now they're
finally going to get to have a say on
how they are governed with this new
constitution it's a important moment and
significant because this vote was
supposed to take place in March but it's
30 years in the making it's been 30
years that governments have tried to
change this Constitution and have this
referendum and it seems that
the leader of the Mali military Junta
has succeeded where previously
elected presidents have failed in
organizing this vote and organizing
conversation around this referendum
there's eight million malians that are
expected to vote today but many of them
will not be able to cast their ballots
because there are large swath of land in
the north and in the center of the
country that are in the hands of arms
groups linked to Al-Qaeda and isil asimi
goitai says that once this referendum
goes through if people vote Yes
then in February 2024 there will be a
presidential election and there'll be a
return to civilian rule under a new
Constitution that would give greater
power to the president but also greater
autonomy to the regions and that would
pave the way for this uh peace Accord
that was signed in 2015 between armed
groups and the government and bring back
some element of sovereignty for malians
and this is what this vote is all about
it's about trying to create legitimacy
and sovereignty for malians that have
felt torn with the violence in a country
that's been under attack for almost 10
years